hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game uh from a tournament that
happened almost 100 years ago it was
played in 1926 in Germany in Hanover so
97 years ago and it's a game between
Aaron nimsovich and Hans Doom now I
apologize for uh the poor quality photo
of Hans Doom um uh I actually found a
nicer photo of his two brothers and his
father as they were a pretty big deal in
theology back then but I was able to use
some photo enhancing software to get
this out of the out of this and I mean
uh from what I was starting with this is
this is actually quite okay so uh plus
I'm not really sure that's even him I'm
pretty sure it is because it kind of
says uh Han's Doom if you if you really
try to make out what the letters say and
I imagine they were naming them from
left to right so it should be him but
then again it might not be so once again
sorry about the poor quality photo uh
but yeah the game is very very nice and
very uh instructive on how to punish
even the slice this sliders the
positional error now it's a tournament
that was basically celebrating uh 50
years of chess club Hanover and they
wanted to make it like a big thing they
invited two very strong International
names for the tournament so it was
basically six local Masters versus two
International well-known uh gentlemen uh
first one being Arun nimsovich here who
I believe needs no introduction and the
other one being one of the strongest
players in the world if we regard pretty
much any chess player in history and
that is Akiba Rubinstein now we're going
to discuss what happened in the
tournament and we're gonna check out the
standings of the tournament but after we
check out this actual game so let's
check it out uh nimsovich has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to C4 he
goes for the English opening we have
Ponte E6 the Asian Court defense by Hans
doom and now uh Ponte E4 with the
Steiner variation C6 preparing D5 uh
sorry uh C5 uh sort of uh stopping D4
and now Knight to C3 with Knight the C6
with Ponta F4 D6 and now Knight to F3
ninja which is now ready to strike in
the center with D4 we have G6 and now uh
Pawn to D4 if this was played uh in a
modern day uh tournament uh pretty much
Knights the D4 uh we would see this on
the board of course black will not will
not allow white to push D4 uh but this
was 1926 so uh G6 was playing with Pawn
to D4 and now Bishop to G7 and it is now
as of move six that this position has
never been repeated again and for very
good reasons it's very very hard to play
this with black and here you will see
why nimsovich is such a big deal and
he's a pretty funny guy he had some
weird moments but uh most of the things
uh he did were were you know pretty top
quality so here he plays D captures on
C5 and it's a move you don't usually do
you capture away from the center uh it
seems like we want to trade Queens but
you know maybe this is just giving up
your advantage a bit uh too too early in
the game but nimsovich has a very clear
plan of what he wants to do the captures
on C5 Queen capture 78 with check now if
you capture with the Knight sort of to
be able to Castle Knight B5 can be very
annoying and you're still gonna have to
move your king so you didn't really
achieve anything so King captures on d8
and now Pawn to E5 and now names of it
shows that he controls E6 F6 uh that his
Knight can come to e for maybe later on
it can come to D6 will pressure on the
C5 so black is uh definitely in trouble
here but it's very instructive how Aaron
does it we have Pawn to H5 now comes the
bishop to E3 we have B6 now defending
the C5 pawn and the iron Castle's Queen
side with check so King the E7 and now
uh how do you how do you improve this
position with white you know that you're
better but how do you improve it uh this
is how Nims original does it now he
takes both of the Bishops and he shifts
this bishop over to this diagonal where
it will definitely be a strong piece and
he will shift the light core Bishop over
to this diagonal and once he does that
his Bishop's pair will be fully
operational and he will be able to take
full advantage of this early positional
Advantage uh weird thing to say I know
so Bishop to F2 we have knighted the H6
and now Bishop to H4 with check King to
f8 and now Bishop to D3 preparing to
bring the bishop over to this diagonal
so black has to prepare for this bishop
to B7 and now Bishop to E4 and now
there's no good way to stop Rook to D7
and once The Rook comes to D7 they don't
call it a pig for nothing so Knights the
A5 uh Doom offers a trade of Bishops
Bishop capture some B7 Knight captures
and now Rook to D7 attacks the Knight
with Rook to B8 defending the Knight and
now at Rook H the D1 doubling up on the
D file King to G8 now trying to
artificially Castle maybe bring the
other Rook into the game uh Bishop to E7
the reason of Bishop D7 is that the
enemies which wants to play Knights the
G5 but he doesn't want to block his
Bishop with the Knight so First bishop
to E7 Knights the F5 now and the Knights
the G5 now you will also see pressure on
the F7 Pawn so Rook the E8 now
threatening to pick up the bishop on E7
and now Bishop to F6
uh Bishop captures on F6 e captures an
F6 and now comes Knight to A5 here uh
trying to uh trying to give up the the
F7 Pawn but uh names which goes for Rook
to d8 instead now threatening Rook
captures Rook uh and how do you stop
this is there a good way uh of stopping
this not really whatever black plays
Black is lost here but here uh Hans Doom
played King to f8 and now names of which
has a forced Checkmate in eight moves
which he also announced back in those
days uh when you had a first Checkmate
on the board and you calculated it
precisely and you your opponent didn't
just want to resign then you also kinda
took this opportunity to humiliate your
opponent a little bit and also show your
uh intellectual Supremacy so here uh
arunimsovich announces mate in eight so
feel free to pause the video and figure
out uh this uh correct series of moves
that nimsovich found while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this um
uh well brilliant brilliant series of
moves and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook one to D7
uh this is how you do it now you
pressure the F7 Pawn once again and you
have to defend it of course if you
capture then just throw captures this
will be uh Checkmate so you have to
defend Knight to H6 by Hans uh and now
Knight C to E4 now the other Knight is
ready to come into the action but it
doesn't seem like there's a threat right
away so here Hans takes this opportunity
to bring the Knight into the game with
an attack and names of its rook and d8
and now uh here it comes Rook captures
an F7 giving up the Rook Knight captures
on F7 if you don't capture it's mating
one just real capture Sunny 80 this is
Checkmate so you have to capture The
Rook Knight captures on F7 uh avoiding
check and now Knight captures an E6 with
check the black king has only one square
King to G8 now comes Rook captures 98
with check King to H7 and now finally
Knight 4 comes the G5 with check Knight
captures if you don't capture if you go
to H6 doesn't really matter knife
captures with checking H7 and now Rook
captures and h8 will be Checkmate uh
everything is uh nicely covered here by
the pawn by the rook and by the Knight
so instead after Knight for the G5 check
we have Knight captures on G5 now comes
Knight captures on G5 check King to H6
and The Rook captures an h8 with
Checkmate so brilliant stuff by
nimsovich taking out a local Master Hans
Doom uh who uh well uh you you can you
can definitely see the difference of
um of strength uh 100 years ago and now
here in this position like I said
um uh when G6 was played nowadays
everyone plays Knight to D4 here there
there's no question about it you just
don't allow uh White uh just take over
the board completely like that and it's
something that okay we humans learned
over the course of the past one 100
years and also uh what I wanted to say
is that the the tournament was played
here uh it's a very nice hotel the
Castle Hotel uh luzenhof uh in um uh in
Hanover Germany so uh here here is where
the tournament was played in here at the
uh distributed the prices after the
tournament so if any of you are from uh
from hanoffa maybe you know this place
and maybe you know you you can check it
out maybe there are some you know maybe
like a signed uh assigned board on the
wall or something uh by by maybe I don't
know or the players the great players
that visited in 1926 you never know once
I was in London and um I I I I I visited
a a local uh uh well a coffee shop where
they also played chess I talked about it
if you guys remember when I was um in
London during the the video wheelchair
championship match between Carlson and
Carolina and there they had uh they have
uh everything saved like the the boards
were were commemorated on the board and
the the signatures of the players that
played there really awesome stuff so you
never know and it's almost 100 years so
maybe they're gonna like have a big um a
big party uh regarding this event I mean
it's it's a pretty big event but yeah
also for those of you who are interested
here are the standings of the tournament
Aaron nimsovich won a half a point ahead
of Akiba Rubinstein and the uh the six
local Masters uh come after that uh
yeah he drew one game and the Kiba
Rubenstein drew two games and of course
the the game that the names of which
Drew uh was against
um uh Akiba Rubinstein and Akiba
Rubinstein Drew of course against
nimsovich and also one other game I
think it was against the against
Friedrich samish as he well was also a a
very strong player and a lot a lot of
theory today uh there's the the the the
semish name like like the semish
variation uh against uh against the
nimzo uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
extra information regarding that story
like I said sorry about the bad photo
but uh of Hans Doom but I I really tried
to make it work I mean it's it's it's
the best I could do uh and yeah I would
like to thank Richard karpo Lauren
Thunder Genesis
reptiles YouTube Kathleen Northrop and
Union for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that's
happened in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I will go
over the other games of this tournament
if there are some nice ones I will show
them as well see you soon